[Music]  okay we got one power girl jumbo combo  gonna leave that hand puddin anything  else you today boy  gotta be her hey I work here  M Allah we are out of time bingo at last  mother look how beautiful you are  it works it works this is no ordinary  leafy mouse but a harbinger of a new way  I be in the floor on Achmed we're up to  questionable activities we need help  Polly quick reporting for duty chef god  help us where can I find your BFF poison  ivy or I can help you find him but  you're gonna put in a good word for me  with the parole board  no really gonna change its role in the  plan humankind have had their chance and  you've had yours  [Music]  I thought we were friends friends don't  like Franco 7 billion  you aren't willing to agree to my terms  why should I help you as insane as you  are you enjoy living how about just a  little something a sweeten the deal  Spa Day autograph fiction for my little  cousin he's real sick okay fine whatever  you're the boss  you